BACK HERE AT HOME, IT'S EASY TO
BECOME NUMB ABOUT MEDIA BIAS
THESE DAYS.
SO "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" IS
KEEPING TRACK OF THE WORST
OFFENDERS OF THE WEEK.
HERE NOW IS CHARLIE KIRK, ONE OF
YOUR FAVORITES FROM TURNING
POINT U.S.A.
ALONG WITH CHAD MOORE FOR
SPECTATOR U.S.A. HERE IN THE
STUDIO WITH HE.
THANKS FOR JOINING ME TONIGHT,
FELLOWS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tammy: LET'S BEGIN.
NOT THE POLITICS END UNTIL THE
MEDIA GIVES US A BREAK.
LET'S BE BEGINNING WITH A
MSNBC'S INTERPRETATION OF A
TRUMP SUPPORTER IN THE MIDST OF
THIS BATTLE.
>> THE BEHAVIORS HERE ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO THE WAY THAT ISIS
MEMBERS ARE.
THEY ARE TRUE BELIEVERS AND THIS
IS THEIR REALITY AND THEY WILL
NOT SURRENDER IT.
THEY'RE DEAD-ENDERS.
>> MALCOLM, I LOVE YOUR
ATTITUDE.
AS WE SAY IN PHILLY, ATTITUDE,
YOU GOT IT.
>> Tammy: HE LOVES THE ATTITUDE
THERE.
JUST LIKE ISIS SUPPORTERS.
CHARLIE, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
THAT?
>> IT'S STUNNING, YOU THINK THEY
CAN'T GO LOWER.
I CAN'T COMPREHEND HOW CHRIS
MATTHEWS THINKS THAT THAT IS
POSITIVE.
THEY WANT TO USE ISIS AND
TRUMP --
>> Tammy: CHRIS MATTHEWS
WOULDN'T LIKE YOUR ATTITUDE.
CHAD, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
>> I HANG OUT WITH A LOT OF
TRUMP SUPPORTERS AND I'M GLAD
THAT I HAVE A RARE MEDICAL
CONDITION THAT WHEN I BOUNCE OFF
OF BUILDINGS, I LAUGH.
I THINK HE'S RIGHT, TO BE
HONEST.
>> IT'S REMARKABLE.
THE GAS LIGHTING THAT HAPPENED.
NOW, THE MEDIA IS SALIVATING
OVER A "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT
TODAY THAT TRUMP IS BRIEFED ON
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT
BEFORE RELEASING AID TO THE
UKRAINE.
>> THE ONLY REASON HE RELEASED
THE AID IS HE GOT CAUGHT IN THIS
SCHEME.
>> THE PRESIDENT DECIDED TO
RELEASE THE AID WHEN HE KNEW HIS
COVER WAS BLOWN.
>> ONCE THEY KNEW THE GIG WAS UP
AND ABOUT TO BE DISCOVERED, THEY
TOOK STEPS TO HAVE THIS FINAL
DEFENSE WE GAVE UP THE AID, NO
HARM, NO FOUL.
>> Tammy: WOW.
CHARLIE, LET ME ASK YOU HERE,
IT'S LIKE IT'S FAN FICTION.
NOTHING YOU CAN BELIEVE.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THEIR
CONSPIRACY FRAME WORK THERE?
>> YEAH, THAT'S THE WORD I WAS
GOING TO USE.
CONSPIRACY FRAME WORK.
GET CAUGHT.
IN ORDER TO GET CAUGHT, YOU HAVE
TO DO NOTHING WRONG.
HE RELEASED THE AID.
HE GAVE UKRAINE DEADLY ARMORY
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA NEVER GAVE
HIM.
ALL WE HAVE HERE IS A FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT'S SON THAT
SATURDAY ON A UKRAINE GAS BOARD
BECAUSE HIS NAME WAS BIDEN AND
HAD NO EXPERIENCE.
>> Tammy: CHADWICK, IS THIS A
GUY THAT GOT CAUGHT BEING
PRESIDENT?
IS THAT HIS CRIME?
>> YEAH, NOT SITTING ON CERTAIN
BOARDS AND HAVING CERTAIN
FRIENDS IN THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
CHARLIE IS RIGHT ABOUT THAT AS
WELL.
>> Tammy: REMEMBER, PEOPLE ARE
LISTENING ONLY TO THAT.
IT'S TROUBLING.
GENTLEMEN, WHAT ABOUT THIS
COMMENT?
FROM CNN DISPARAGING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
>> I'M REFERRING TO TRUMP'S
ORGANIZATION AND FOLLOWERSHIP AS
A DESTRUCTIVE CULT WHERE PEOPLE
ARE BEING FED PROPAGANDA AND NOT
ENCOURAGED TO THINK FOR
THEMSELVES.
>> Tammy: CHARLIE, THIS IS THE
SECOND TIME WE'VE SEEN THIS.
THIS IS NEW.
NOW MEDIA NOT JUST ATTACKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT GOING AFTER
THE SUPPORTERS, WHETHER IT'S
ISIS FIGHTERS AND THIS KIND OF
NONSENSE.
HOW FAR CAN THIS GO, YOU THINK?
>> ADD THAT TO THE LIST OF
DEPLORABLE AND FLYOVER COUNTRY
AND WALL
AND WAMART SPELLY PEOPLE.
THE LEFT THINKS WE'RE BAD
PEOPLE.
THEY THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
MORALLY WRONG WITH
CONSERVATIVES.
WE LOOK AT THE LEFT AND SAY
THEY'RE WRONG.
THEY LOOK AT US AND THEY'RE
WE'RE BAD.
LIKE THEY'RE CONTINUING -- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF STRATEGY
THIS IS.
INSULT 60 MILLION PEOPLE AND
HOPE TO WIN THEM BACK.
IF THIS IS THEIR STRATEGY,
CONTINUE TO DO IT.
I'M NOT SURE IT WILL WORK.
>> Tammy: I DON'T THINK THEY
INTEND TO WIN US BACK.
>> I THINK YOU MIGHT BE RIGHT.
FIRST, I THOUGHT THEY WERE
ACTING LIKE A CULT IN THE STATE
OF THE UNION WHERE ALL THE
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS WORE WHITE
THAT LOOKED CULTY TO ME.
>> Tammy: AMERICANS GET
PASSIONATE ABOUT POLITICS.
THERE'S NO BONES ABOUT THAT.
THIS DYNAMIC OF NOT